there's definitely a wedding coming this
season it's a pretty little wire wedding
a PLL wedding an Emison reunion and a
friendship rattles et has rosewood
romance spoilers on all your favorite
couples I feel like maybe Toby and
Spencer could be getting back together
but then there's also this girlfriend
that he has
I feel like Spey lab fans are just lost
caleb fans and it begs me to question
what is true love if these characters do
not get back together right I think a
lot of people when they when they first
kind of like saw Hanna and Caleb kiss
that they were like oh my god they're
back together again and it's like no
actually like relationships can be very
confusing and there can be those old
wounds that are opened up or old
attractions that are still there and
like they have to be handled they have
to be talked about and it doesn't
necessarily mean the end of a
relationship you know Oh Spencer find
out about that kiss
Spencer's a smart lady she's gonna know
what is going to happen with Caleb there
was a kiss at the end of season six yes
you know I think those two will always
have so much love for each other because
they were each other's first real love
srong and told me that Spencer finds out
about this kid yes how does she handle
that and how does Caleb handle that not
to excuse the cheating because I'm not
and of that but they both handle it
pretty well we don't even know if
Hannah's alive so I think there will
always be some elements of hail about
there this is a really romantic season
so with romance comes a lot of emotion
fans really want aria and Ezra backs
together and it looks like we are headed
that way yeah I mean she has this great
guy in Boston who could be a safe choice
for her but as far as just the one that
she can't quite get rid of and I don't
think she wants him to go away so it'll
be interesting to see you know which
road she goes down because it could lead
to like two very different lives I think
in her heart she knows what she wants
anything that you can cheese about the
aria and Ezra future there is a lot I
mean I I work a lot with Ian there are
some pretty impactful things that happen
you know something from his past comes
back up and something pretty special
happens in their lives so Marlene told
me that there is a wedding there is yeah
you be involved in that wedding as they
as the bride I could be involved in some
way I think a lot of people will be very
pleased with who it is
Ali's husband is not who he says he is
not a nice person
yeah Alison she she goes crazy um he's
at fault obviously she thinks she's
going mad but is she really no does your
character find out that your husband's
maybe not up yes yes yes quickly okay
yeah how does Emily play into that will
you guys get back together emily has
always been like Alison's pit bull she's
like her defender so yeah you get to see
that come out in her cute eveson scenes
that you can choose I know we do we have
some really cute ones in the hospital we
have
a lot of just like really sweet
comforting things okay um you know you
never know
you